I lived in Spain for a little and people over there. Spain love him really?
Oh yeah. Doing and they were just getting wind of like him being a bad guy.
And they were just like, bro. Yeah. It was pretty incredible. What he, like,
they were all watching. Let me ask you again. What happened was pretty bad,
but he took a wooden ship across the ocean. Yeah.
And he named them after girls and then he showed up and just was like,
all right, you guys are doing what I say. Yeah. Yeah. I have on a metal helmet.
Yeah. Totes metal helmet. I'm coming in with my hat on sideways.
And that's what it is. And you guys are gonna listen. You're you know,
like it's 1492. Why are you still making underwear out of leaves?
horse. But I thought you're going to do what we say. Yeah. I would do it.
I would've, just been like, I literally, if I was Christopher Columbus,
when I got off on the shores with that horse, I would've taken that horse.
Run into the shores, let the native and all the native Americans see me.
And then just start sucking that horses dead just to show them that I'm in
charge just right in front of him, just on the news, double barrel,
blow job and let that and shoot,
let that horse shoot its load all over my face and then just get up and be an
army master now. Yeah, absolutely. That would hold up today.
If I saw a guy pull up off a boat with a horse. Yeah. I'd be like,
I'm going to listen to what he's got. Exactly. Yeah. He's got some ideas. Yeah.
That's what I would do at any of these protests. I was like,
if I was at one of these protests and the cops were acting like,
I would just start jerking off their horses. And then what are they going to do?
What are you going to do here with a stick? Try to grab a horse's Dick. Yeah,
dude. That's no good. I'll. Are you kidding me, dude? What do you mean?
You can't grab a horse? His Dick from bum. Pennsylvania. People got her. Yeah.
People who just got arrested from horses where I'm from, dude. Wow. I mean,
what else?
I don't think they can get COVID it's too dangerous to a human shut out.
Perry County, shout out Perry County doing Mechanicsburg.
That's con that's Cumberland County, please.
[Inaudible].